I heard as you've gone through this
you've noticed what we were sent many
times before which is that the
construction of diagram is a critical
piece it's a critical step and wrapping
your hair around what our family's going
on here okay um this is not uncommon in
terms of the number of lines you have
flying around your diagram in fact this
is this is not that bad as I was just
thinking through some of the other
clinics questions there this is about in
the middle very few have less that's
some that ball so good morning so
therefore investing the type of door
what's going on and like I said we're
gonna use this diagram be type in a few
minutes is definitely worth that one
what's your sacrifice you know what I'm
saying like Oh
Lori's our girl takes your crema well
it's worth it okay we're ready now let's
have a got this the first two therefore
questions that they asked and they all
do CLE together is really show that the
equation of the normal to be lives at
the point P is and they provided an
equation so you know how we've been
asking all like to be quite this we put
that ball up quite clearly they asked
you to show these two demonstrators
so all the proofs that we've gone
through like if I have demonstrated a
proof to you it's important that you
understand the way that the logic piece
yeah so you can use it as it is yes
okay now have a look at it very briefly
are we talking in parametric form or
Cartesian form
this is Cartesian right this is the
ellipse and there's no sign of cause
insight at least like the last question
but that's to do triangles not to do
with the
crap parent reports so therefore I want
the tangent there right I've got to I've
got tension out of the normal bear right
what two things do I need will three
things do I need to get an equation I'm
going to need the gradient there which
will give me the great in there and then
I need to the two coordinates right
which I already have that's kind of nice
right so therefore I'm going to start
with the equation of the Ivy on ellipse
and if I can try to get to a equation
for the normal and I want the gradient
in Cartesian but what's the quickest
path there we've looked at they're
already implicit differentiation is
clearly the quickest path I mean I could
go through the rigmarole of trailing
while the subject but we don't need to
we don't need to are you taking this
whole line having done this before I'm
not even gonna really good money to us
transformation of this and then
differentiate every term with respect to
X ok is that Alright x squared that one
are x squared is just a constant so when
I differentiate x squared I get 2x
would you differentiate this Y squared
on B squared again you've got that one
on B spoon taking out the front as the
constant then what you differentiate Y
squared you've got to do two things
it's chain rule right so you do the
outside and the inside or the first
direction whichever you like I'm going
to do the outside first so it's y
squared so that means I'm gonna bring
the car down and I will reduce the power
by one so that's fine
and then I differentiate the inside the
inside function is y so what's the
derivative dy/dx very good sir I mean
that's the whole point of doing it you
kiss it right there we go so this having
been evolved a bit more food we don't
have to see me to say I'm doing this
fine physically projection this step
makes it clearer but if you want to for
your own reference so when you come back
to this you don't look at that line of
you what a bit is going on you could put
that out of this the same this is by
differentiation
okay just for yourself you don't need to
put that up you know the light makes it
clear now what am I trying to do I try
to get the derivative right so I'm just
gonna reiterate a little bit I'm going
to divide through by 2 which will leave
you with a Y on B squared times dy DX
here and I'm also going to cut this X on
a square because I thought about you
ribbon I'm going to cut it over the
other side
is that right
and then I'm going to divide both sides
by Y and B square okay that gives me by
the
okay actually it's been a funny way to
write up show their face unless see
that's why yes
so yeah okay so I'm not finished yet so
I've differentiated right I've
differentiated but what I want is not
the derivative not the grading here
I actually of the normal remember that
okay so therefore I can say I can say
the the gradient at P right before I get
to the gradient for normal the great
help of P is just this 4x lot wider like
that's the X in the Y that I'm
particularly interested in right so
therefore I'm going to say I'll write up
the correct order this time this is the
actual gradient at P but I want the
gradient that's perpendicular to P yes
I'm interested in the room so that's
what makes it positive and upside down
so that's gonna give me this which is
what you've just notice that's where I'm
kidding and thankfully I do look at the
formulas they've given it to you they've
left it in point green uniform that's
kind of nice right so there's not too
much work here I would say therefore the
equation of the gradient
sorry accredited at the normal he is and
me really all I'm gonna do is something
like I think having demonstrated this I
have knowing that excellent whatnot is
the point which is given I can actually
just say there's the radium and in
a little is a little bit unconventional
that they usually pick so why not
indicate a point that's on the ellipse
but whatever they're using it and it's
not that complicated you know so Tara I
have demonstrated equator in the normal
so far so good